President Trump is signaling a shift in
the u.s. approach to North Korea since
the death of American college student
audio war Muir the president has
apparently lost faith in China's ability
to pressure the country mr. Trump says
that China tried but failed to help curb
North Korea's nuclear program Margaret
Brennan is at the White House with more
on this Margaret good morning Hugh good
morning president Trump's national
security advisors will meet today with
top Chinese officials here in Washington
they'll press for ramped up sanctions on
North Korea and threatened you to
lateral action if Beijing doesn't comply
it's a total disgrace what happened to
honor that should never ever be allowed
to happen
president Trump said otto warmbier life
might have been saved if North Korea
released him sooner suggesting that
President Obama may bear some blame for
failing to secure his freedom frankly if
he were brought home sooner I think the
result would have been a lot different
multiple Obama administration officials
told CBS News that North Korea refused
to engage with or allow the u.s. any
access to warmbier former Obama aide Ned
Price insisted warmbier had been a high
priority our efforts on his behalf never
ceased price said even in the waning
days of the administration with Kim
jong-un still holding three Americans
and continuing missile tests the Trump
administration has leaned on China for
leverage White House press secretary
Sean Spicer claimed that strategy has
shown some success we've had
I think positive movement on China over
the past five months of this
administration and will continue to work
with them and others to put the
appropriate pressure on North Korea yet
45 minutes later President Trump tweeted
that the strategy had failed while I
greatly appreciate the efforts of
President Xi and China to help with
North Korea he said it is not worked out
at least I know China tried that
admission indicates relations could turn
contentious yet stop short of a return
to mr. Trump's hardline position from
the campaign trail
what I would do very simply is say China
this is your baby this is your problem
you
solve the problem and next week
President Trump will meet with the new
South Korean president at the White
House he revealed to Norah O'Donnell his
hope to negotiate directly with North
Korea if we achieve that freeze in North
Korea's programs then I believe we will
be able to sit down and talk with the
North Koreans to achieve complete
dismantling and I hope the president
Trump agrees with my view now China does
favor direct talks with North Korea to
negotiate a peace treaty but US
officials fear that still won't
eliminate the nuclear threat posed by
North Korea
president Trump appears to be giving
China one last try to fix it all right
Margaret got it thank you very much